So, let's have a real conversation. If I
had to start from zero, no savings, no
investments, no financial cushion, what
would I do? Starting from zero, starting
over can be overwhelming, but it is
possible with clear intention and with a
clear strategy. So, in today's video,
I'm going to talk about what I would do
if I was starting from the very
beginning from zero. No shame, no
judgment, and no fluff. Just real clear
action steps on what I would do, what
will I would do if I were to start over.
Let's get into it. Hi everyone, my name
is Bola Shoki. I'm the founder and CEO
of Clever Finance. I'm also the author
of the Clever Girl Finance book series
and my most recent book, Choosing to
Prosper. Welcome to Cleverirl Finance
TV.
So, if I was starting from scratch,
here's what I would do. The first thing
I would do would be to take a good hard
look at my current numbers. So, I'd want
to understand what is my current income?
How much do I have coming in? Is it an
inconsistent or consistent income? I'd
want to understand what my expenses are.
How much is going out every month? What
am I paying for recurrently or on a
one-off basis for the next few months?
I'd also determine what debts I have and
what that debt is costing me. And I'll
also look at what my core essentials
are. What is the cost of my core
essentials so I could shift myself into
into survival mode. And this is
basically being able to cover my food,
my housing, my transportation, my core
utilities, and any core medications,
etc. that my household might need. For
example, my kids have year round
allergies. And so really looking at my
numbers will help me gain clarity as to,
okay, Bola, you're starting from zero,
but where do you actually stand with
your finances? What is your current
current financial situation? And this
will help me plan my next step. For me,
this wouldn't be the time to sugarcoat
anything because I cannot build a plan,
a strategy without clarity. And so, the
key here for me is to gain that clarity
so I can set my focus and set my
intentions. Number two, I would cut my
spending to the bare essentials. Again,
keep in mind, I'm starting from zero and
so I'm trying to pick myself up, get
back on my feet, and even if I had a
high income, right, I would focus on
just the bare essentials. So, this is me
going into survival mode so that I can
kind of gather myself together and get
things back on track. So, in order to
get in survival mode, I would pause on
all non-essential spending. This
basically means anything that has to do
with getting my nails done, getting my
hair done, I can do those things myself
for a short period of time. I would
cancel and use subscriptions, uh the
streaming services I don't watch, don't
use so that I can funnel as much money
as I can into building savings. I would
cook at home. I would pause completely
on ordering in or eating out. Again,
this is bulla in survival mode. I would
also cut out emotional or convenient
shopping. So, I would not allow myself
to go to the mall for a short period of
time to buy clothes or cosmetics. I have
enough of that at home. And I would set
a weekly barebones spending cap.
Basically, this is the maximum I can
spend and I would stick to it. And
essentially the reasons for me doing
this I mentioned earlier is because I am
being crystal clear on wanting to start
over. And so yes, I would love to get my
hair done. I'd love to get my nails
done. But for me personally, I would put
a pause on those things so that I could
gather myself, put some savings aside,
and then get back to it. So when you're
thinking about yourself, if you are
starting over, if you need to start
over, you found yourself in a financial
situation where you know things are not
going well and you're starting from
zero, what do you need to cut out to get
into survival mode so that you can start
putting money aside to get back on your
feet? These are not permanent cuts for
me. These are temporary cuts and for you
they would be temporary cuts just so
that you can get back on track. Once
things are a bit more stabilized, you
can go back to doing the things you love
and to treating yourself as well. So, by
cutting back and just getting into
survival mode, this essentially allows
me to be really, really focused on my
spending and put every single dollar
towards a priority. Number three, I
would focus on fast cash opportunities.
Keep in mind, I said fast cash
opportunities, not get rich quick
schemes. There is a difference here. So,
I would ask myself, how can I bring
money in the door quickly? How can I
bring in some cash to help me accelerate
putting money aside and getting back on
my feet? And this is what I would do. I
would consider selling unused items in
my house. So, tech items, clothing. I
have so many clothes, furniture that's
not being used, old kids items, things
in my garage, things in my basement. I
would get so creative with selling these
items, um, unused items or items that I
no longer need to bring in extra cash.
And I would do that on places like eBay,
Facebook Marketplace, even have a garage
sale or take items to my local
consignment store. I would also think
about offering a service based on my
skill set, right? Maybe a service I
could offer on Task Rabbit or something
like that. I would tap into my skills uh
in terms of offering those services. So,
for example, freelancing, coaching,
speaking, those are things that I know I
personally am really good at and I could
offer a service there. just start
thinking about yourself. What kind of
skills can you monetize? So, I'd look
for a part-time gig that maybe perhaps
even paid me tips in addition to my
full-time business. And so, for you
might be a full-time job, but things
like food delivery or doing Uber, etc.
Those can help to bring in some extra
cash on the side. And I may even think
about offering virtual admin services to
small businesses because as a small
business owner, I know how small
businesses work and I can definitely add
value there. So the goal is not about
perfection. The goal is about making
progress to get yourself back on your
feet. And some of these things to may
sound crazy like why would BOA want to
do any of those things? But remember in
this scenario, I'm starting from zero. I
am in survival mode. I'm trying to bring
as much money in the door as possible so
that I can pay my bills. I can get back
on my feet. I can start saving again and
eventually start investing because right
now I don't have anything. So, it's all
about getting creative and stepping
outside of my comfort zone. I haven't
had a um odd job in years. If I need to
bring money in, best believe I'm going
to go out and do what I need to do to
bring that money in the door. Number
four, I would build a starter emergency
fund. So, once I have money coming into
the door, my first priority is to put
aside my first $500, my first $1,000,
and then my first $1,500. And what this
buffer emergency fund is going to allow
me to do is have a bit of peace of mind
because $1,500 can cover utilities. It
can cover putting food on the table. It
can cover getting a simple car repair,
uh, changing my tires, buying an
emergency plane ticket. $1,500, while
it's not a ton of money, can do a ton of
stuff if you have money coming in. And
so, I'd prioritize that emergency fund
and use it as my buffer account until
I'm able to add even more to it. And
this is not money I'm going to keep in
my checking account. So, I'm not tempted
to spend it. I'm going to put it in a
separate account where I can access it
easily, but I'm not going to have a
check or a debit card that I put in my
wallet and just swipe, swipe, swipe
whenever I get tempted. Number five, I
would create a simple and flexible
budget. And by simple, I really mean
simple. And this is me going with a 50
3020 budget. And essentially this is
where I would put 50% of my um income
towards needs, 30% to goals, savings,
debt payoff, and 20% to flexibility or
small wants because during this process
of starting over, you might experience
burnout. And the reason why I've chosen
the 50 30 20 budget for me is because in
this season of starting over, there's no
need to complicate things. This is a
very simple and effective budget.
However, you can modify this 50 30 20 to
work for your situation or you can
adjust the percentages based on what is
going to work best for you. So, you may
decide to do a 70 20 10 budget. So, for
example, you may choose to do the 8020
budget. You may have really large needs
and expenses right at this time. So,
maybe 80% is going towards your needs,
but then you carve out 20% to go go
towards your goals like your savings,
like paying down debt, like investing.
So, you want to adjust this budget to in
terms of percentages to work for you and
make it as simple as possible so you
don't feel overwhelmed and so you don't
get burned out by trying to pursue a
complex budget, especially right now. By
the way, if you are enjoying this video,
I'd love for you to subscribe to this
channel. Uh, check out Clever Girl
Finance website. We offer over 30 plus
completely free courses and over 40 plus
completely free worksheets. You can also
check out our podcast called the Clever
Girls Know podcast wherever you listen
to podcast episodes. And don't forget to
tell your best girlfriends about Clever
Girl Finance as well. And be sure to
check out the Clever Finance book
series. There are five books in this
series, including my new workbook called
My Wealth Plan. Okay, let's get back to
the video. Number six, I would choose a
debt payoff plan. So, if I had debt that
I was tackling in addition to starting
over, I would pick one of the following.
I would either pick the snowball method
where I organize my debt by lowest
balance to highest balance and
prioritize paying off my top debt first.
That would be my debt with the lowest
balance first. Or I would pick the
avalanche method where I organize my
debt by the debt that's costing me the
most. So the debt that has the highest
interest rate and I would prioritize
paying as much more than the minimum
payment to that number one priority debt
as possible. Next, I would pick up my
phone once I've organized all my debt
and determined uh the method I want to
use to pay my debt down, whether it's
snowball or avalanche. I would pick up
my phone and call my creditors, call my
lenders, and try to negotiate a better
interest rate, an adjusted payment
timeline, a hardship request if
possible, if they have hardship
programs, depending on what my finances
are looking at looking like. One thing
to keep in mind when it comes to debt is
that you can always negotiate. There's
always room to negotiate. And even if
you can't, the worst response you can
get is no, it is not available to you
and you go ahead with the plan that you
have created. But if you are tackling
debt and you find yourself maybe unable
to pay, definitely pick up your phone
and call your lender and ask about
hardship programs, ask about deferred
payments so that they do not um start
making negative remarks on your credit
because you've just ghosted them. You
want to have the conversation. you want
to try to negotiate and then put your
plan in place and based on the income
you have coming in and the budget you
have created, you can start working on
paying down your debt. Number seven, I
would start learning about money every
day. And this one is huge. This is
because knowledge is power. If I'm
starting from zero and I have gaps in my
financial literacy, I am going to focus
on learning as much as I can. And I
would do things like spend 10 to 15
minutes a day learning about how to
manage my money, how to budget properly,
how credit works. I would learn about
how investing works. I would learn how
to grow my income. And I would really
learn I really prioritize learning how
to build long-term wealth. How can I
combine all these things I have learned
to build long-term wealth for myself so
I don't find myself in the position
where I have to start from zero ever
again. And guess what? When it comes to
learning about financial literacy or
improving your financial literacy
skills, Clever Girl Finance has over 30
plus completely free courses. We have
over over 40 plus completely free
worksheets. And there is the book series
that you can start with to help you get
back on your feet. And I'd also focus on
creating a mindset shift. Basically
telling myself that by learning new
things, I'm going to be creating new
results for myself. Number eight, I
would set up automation. And this
basically means automating whatever part
of my finances I can, especially if I
have a consistent income. So, I would
automate bill payments. That way, I
don't have to have that mental
gymnastics about what is due, when is
due. And I would also prioritize
automating my savings, even if it's only
$5 a week, $10 every two weeks, whatever
that amount may be. I would automate an
amount to go to savings automatically so
that I can start building that
consistent habit of saving over time. as
my income increases, I can save even
more through automation. So, automation
is a great way to uh get your savings to
be consistent, to stay on top of your
bill payments so that you're not paying
bills late. And studies show that when
you automate um you save more money on
average than people who don't because
when you don't automate and your
paycheck hits your bank account um
before you get a chance to save,
something always comes up. There's
always a distraction, always a bill.
There's something that's always going to
cause you to spend the money, right?
However, if you have automated it, the
money automatically goes to your savings
account. It automatically goes to your
investments, to your bills before you
get a chance to be like, "Oh, should I
buy this? Should I buy should I not buy
this? Oh, I'll save later. I'll save
after this. XYZ." You don't you don't
give yourself the opportunity to start
having those conversations with yourself
because the money has already been
automatically put aside for your future
self. Number nine, I would start
investing as soon as I could. So once I
have my small cushion of emergency
savings set aside, my income is
consistent, I would open up up a Roth uh
IRA, a traditional IRA or a 401k
depending on my type of employment. And
I will start putting small amounts of
money to start investing. You don't need
a huge amount of money to get started
with investing. You can start with very
small amounts. And the key to building
wealth with investing over time is
staying consistent. As your income
increases, you will increase your
investments. And what's great about
investing is that your money is working
for you even when you're asleep. And
this is because of the power of
compounding dividends that your money
can earn when the investment is doing
well and also appreciation which is the
growth in value of your investment. And
I will also stick to simplified
investments which basically would be
things like lowcost index funds or ETFs
that offer me broad diversification and
min minimal risk. Number 10, I would
take guilt-free breaks to celebrate my
wins. So, starting over is not a walk in
the park. It's going to be tough. You're
going to need to give yourself grace and
patience. You may have setbacks. Things
may not go according to plan, but as
long as you set the intention and you
keep making progress, that is what
counts. And so as I'm on that journey,
making that progress, navigating set
step setbacks, I'm going to be
intentional about celebrating my wins in
a way that makes sense, that's not
derailing me for my grow from my goals.
It could be making sure that I'm able to
get my favorite coffee every week or get
my nails done or do something that makes
me feel good, treat myself to something
that makes me feel happy about the
progress I'm making without derailing my
progress. It's really important that you
celebrate your wins and you empower
yourself to keep moving forward because
there are times on a financial journey
where you know you may feel low, your
emotions might be low and you just want
a pickme up. And by celebrating your
wins, you can do just that for yourself.
Um, we talk a lot about discipline when
it comes to improving your finances,
starting over, or even growing wealth.
However, discipline does not mean
deprivation. It does not mean
punishment. you still want to be able to
enjoy life's little pleasures while you
were on this journey, right? And so I
would build in those uh guilt-free
rewards for myself. And I definitely
encourage you to do that for yourself as
well within reason. So if you are
starting from zero today, you're having
to start over, starting from the
beginning, understand that this is not
your final destination. This is you
taking those first new steps to get to
somewhere different, someone somewhere
big, somewhere huge, somewhere that's
going to somewhere that's going to make
you feel empowered and proud of yourself
at the end of the day. So don't be
demotivated. Don't be discouraged. It is
possible to rebuild. It is possible to
start over. It is possible to start from
zero and build something incredible,
something that you'll be so proud of. So
just start with one step today. What is
the one action you can take today to get
your finances back on track? And then
keep going. And then keep track of your
wins. Journal how you are doing. Every
time something good happens, write it
down. It doesn't have to be anything
massive or elaborate. But those small
wins are very motivating. And over time,
when you look back to see the progress
you have made, you will realize how far
you have come. Because sometimes when
you're in the motions of rebuilding,
it's hard to see the progress until
you're able to look back and see how far
you've come. So, by documenting your
wins, you'll be able to do just that.
So, I would love for you to share in the
comments what is the first step you're
going to take today to work on
rebuilding your finances if you're
starting from zero or if you find that
you have to start over. Perhaps what you
share will inspire someone else who is
also starting over as well. I hope you
have found this video useful. If you
have, please subscribe to this channel,
hit the like button below, tell your
best girlfriend about Clever Girl
Finance, and be sure to stop by our
website to check out our 30 plus free
courses, our free worksheets, and also
to schedule a completely free mentor
call. So, one of the things that Clever
Finance offers is free mentor calls when
you sign up for a course. So, we would
love to talk with you and support you on
your journey. Thanks for being here and
I will talk to you in the next video.
[Music]